the American superstore once stopped
shopping for everything you could ever
want or need do you want to be thinner
fatter happier sadder are you looking
for friendship or solitude or even love
that's actually a cubic zirconia
knockoff
it's called plastic Claire what happened
to the $8 once we're all sold out of
those sorry but this one's only two
dollars more I get it
the advertise the cheap jewelry to get
the suckers in the door then you push
the expensive stuff well I wouldn't use
the word suckers or expensive for
jewelry Shh
fine I got Stan line for cigarettes
anyhow great I hope you and your fiance
are very happy together and that you
don't procreate Glenn uh-huh I'm taking
a mental health break okay have fun now
reflect just checking over your new
higher forms American citizen nice no
dependents me neither
unless you count my Birds just doesn't
say anywhere on here if you've got a
girlfriend
I didn't is there some space for that
there's this section here is there
anything else we should know some people
like to volunteer it oh um then also no
no okay well I will just jot that down
then but you are a hitter sexual right
is it are you allowed to ask that no we
always keep the best roles right in the
middle
oh wait no no let me help you with that
oh no no I'm fine I guess fine I work
here I just like mine it's my job to
help customers so you've worked here
since when uh since right now I'm it's
actually my first day oh I know I don't
seem like the kind of person who would
work in a place like this yeah that's
why I was so surprised I was like wow
yeah what's he doin cleaning up toilet
paper I think it's because you just you
have this very intelligent educated more
cultured quality I mean compared to them
yeah okay look I get that you're come
from ending me but it might sound a
little condescending so you know oh yeah
thanks no I wouldn't want to sound
condescending in front of somebody who
works here right hey can I run out for
two minutes this thing is kicking my
bladder like it owes in money oh you
know what I'm actually not sure of
course I'll take Carly off Express and
Vivian can bag so take as long as you
need
oh thanks little tip don't let the other
workers here know how much better than
them you are they hate that I don't know
why maybe because it sounds
condescending welcome
I'm uh
you